obviously like like Latins are pretty
conservative uh uh do any of your girl's
family ever seen in your comedy and and
like hit her up about it and be like yo
what's wrong with it like oh yeah yeah
well that see it's it you know that see
that's it it's a weird well because you
you have obviously heavily in the music
game it's an interesting thing Society
Comics talk about this when I think
about this a lot it's like a comic right
will get scrutinized for word you know
my this joke or that joke right you know
Kevin Hart uh a home of full tweet can't
host the Oscars whatever but then on
that same show they have like Eminem on
who does rap lyrics about killing his
ex-wife and put it in a truck and raping
his mind so you're like how come rap
gets a pass and and Comics don't it's a
it's this thing in society that no one
can really explain and I think that it's
interesting like you know like like
sometimes I feel like you know as as as
a white guy sometimes I'm like yo man
especially in this like if I say
anything oh homophobe you're a racist
and I'm like yo honestly the most
homophobic racism people I've ever met
in my life are not white dude they are
so Latino and black some of the Latino
and black people I've met I'm like what
are you a Nazi you can't say that you
know but it's true you're so right no
it's like I'm like but I'm the [ __ ]
bad guy I'm like holy [ __ ] like you
can't you can't give us homophobic
people in my life are definitely people
of color yeah 100 dude some of the [ __ ]
that I've heard at Family barbecues on
my girls side I'm like I literally I
want to call my Senator I like I'm like
I'm gonna I'm contacting the police
but you know I'm the one with [ __ ]
Hitler head so I'd be in trouble for it
but but I'm like but I'm like yo but it
it's one of those things where but see
that's the thing that's the thing I I
think too is is you know getting you
know dating outside your race is you
realize you know yes racism race I
understand that but it's it's really
tribalism that's what it is it's like
people want to just they feel safe with
people that look like that and sound
like them and come through the same
struggles as them so that's why you know
you'll have I believe like you know say
like you know sometimes you'll have like
Latino people that like say the N word
and you'll have a white person like well
how come they can say the n-word and I
can it's like well because the Latino
and black struggle is very similar in
this country where the white struggle is
different so that's why so it's a
tribalism they've become a tribe but
they've said hey this is always a white
person that's that's mad about it always
yeah yeah like a white lady yes 37 yeah
got a few cats yeah well I like it's
funny like as it like I guess because
i'm you know heavily in the Latino
culture I always think that too I'm like
why do I people care I'm like just dude
I want to tell white people just shut
the [ __ ] up it's that guilt [ __ ] yeah
dude it's not your job to police
everybody's feelings I'm like just shut
up you're not the bar of what what's
offensive yeah yeah like if if a white
person is more offended than the person
the joke's actually about like it's
probably a good joke